no matter where you go here the London
chess classic you will find top chess
players one great player who I played
many many years ago I always remind him
that I nicked him a bit his Grandmaster
Julian Hudson who's doing the commentary
here in the VIP room
Julian taught me what it feels like to
be at the London chess classic I'm sure
you come every year I've been coming
here since 2009 and see all these great
players in London playing phenomenal
chess it's just so exciting I mean it's
it's definitely one of the highlights of
the year for me I think for the whole of
England watching this chess tool I mean
I think this is probably the strongest
form of all time we've ever had in this
country yes it is rating wise definitely
up there you see these fantastic players
it's a younger generation as a matter of
fact so many young players here which
are feeling seeing that the shifting the
changing of the guard
well basically these guys they very
rarely play a bad move I mean their
general level of play is just phenomenal
they really are and they're tactically
very alert and you you can see how hard
it is to beat these guys I mean they're
just not making really many what I would
call serious mistakes you don't want to
jump in there and take a few swings
absolutely not I mean I must admit I
love watching them and it's great listen
to them talk about the games afterwards
they and they all seem quite relaxed
here actually they look like they're
having a good time as well well I don't
know if some of them are having a good
time I saw Nakamura get punched in the
face in round one you you seem to really
not appreciate Maxine but Sheila grubs
not sacrificing on three on see three in
his game against Einon well I mean
obviously Maxine knows I mean he's he's
a world expert on this but it just felt
the flow of the game it felt like rook
takes c3 was the right move I mean and
maybe if rook takes c3 doesn't work
there maybe black's done something
fundamentally wrong because this move d5
it just doesn't feel right this position
now looks really promising for white so
if you just feel the logic of the
position rook takes III felt like it was
the right move and if it doesn't work
there maybe blacks hold position you
sort of think about something else
earlier well providing as commentary
here is Julian Hudson thank you so much
for joining us and we'll let you get
back to the group who seems to be very
lively and enjoying well every bit of
the announcement we're very lucky here
because we have all sorts of people here
we've got
some great legends of the game John
Spellman John and Adi Mortazavi
so we got some great people here who
sort of really make it help and sort of
come up with some fantastic suggestions
so it's just really good fun in here
absolutely I saw Dwayne Jones and Nigel
short you you just throw a rock and you
hit a British legend in this place
the London chess classic always an
entertaining place to be make sure you
take a visit because it's just a bit of
fun